[Music]
rush limbaugh in some trouble i
mentioned 12 companies have suspended
advertising on rush limbaugh's radio
show after a rush called a georgetown
law student who spoke out in favor of
birth control a [ __ ] and a prostitute
now limbaugh says he's not worried about
losing these advertisers in fact several
new businesses have offered to sponsor
his show i'm talking about companies
like adelson's wife cages they're going
to uh
the asshat cigar company wants to be in
on this
i like that guy
the revisionist history channel
apparently
very excited
and finally the [ __ ] plug also by
adelson's and i think
[Applause]
yeah that was a good one
i just wanted the camera off me for a
second
don't show that no no no no no no don't
show it again now
i'm not doing it you know that after the
show the prison be like i don't think we
should have gone to it so many times
and you know it's not me doing it it's
the director doing it
yeah
okay i've never heard him speak before
it was just fun to hear